A decision has just been reached
in Mark Meadows bid to make his case
in the sprawling Georgia
election interference probe
moved to a federal court.
A federal judge has just rejected
the former Trump
White House
chief of staff's arguments reach.
Dealing a major setback not only Meadows
but also potentially
the former president,
Donald Trump, who just yesterday
notified the judge overseeing the case
that he, too, may try to move his case
from state to federal court.
CNN's Sara
Murray is following
all of these important
developments for us.
What more can you tell us
about this monumental decision?
Well, Wolf,
we have been waiting for this
ruling, right?
Because Mark Meadows, the former
White House chief of staff,
was the first one out of the gate
saying he wants to move the charges
against him in state court
to federal court.
A big part of the reason
that he was doing
this was because he wanted to go
to federal court
and argue
essentially that he had immunity
from these charges
and that they should be tossed out.
And what we are now
hearing from the federal judge
is that Mark
Meadows did not meet the threshold
he needed to meet in order to move this
to federal court.
In fact,
the judge says the court concludes
that Meadows
has not met
even the, quote, quite low threshold
for removal.
Now, the judge does note
this is a novel case.
This is a racketeering case.
But he goes on to say that
the court finds
that the color of the office
of White House Chief of staff,
which is what Mark Meadows need to prove,
needed to prove
that he was acting under
the color of the office,
did not include working with
or working for the Trump campaign
so essentially, these activities
that Meadows engaged in
after the 2020 election allegedly
related to trying to overturn Georgia's
election results
had more to do with campaign work
that had to do with his White House work
so they don't meet the threshold.
The other thing
I think is important to note
is that the judge goes on to say,
even though he is making this decision
about the Meadows
case, it's
not going to have any effect
on the outcome of other defendants.
He's essentially going to let them
go forward, put their arguments forward.
We know
Jeffrey Clarke,
who's a former Justice
Department official, has
a hearing scheduled to do this.
We know a couple of people
who served as fake electors
for Donald Trump in Georgia
also have a hearing scheduled
because they want to move
to federal court.
So the judge is saying,
I will hear all your arguments
separately and I will decide them.
But it certainly doesn't portend
well for them
that Mark
Meadows did not meet the bar here.
You're absolutely right.
Stay with us.
I want to bring in our legal
and political experts
to discuss this important development
right now.
And Jamie Gangel,
how significant is this?
I think it's very significant,
even though, as Sara points out,
this ruling,
the judge said, does not
necessarily mean
it will carry over to other people.
It does set a bar.
So I think it is bad
news in that the judge is saying,
you know,
you have exceeded your role
as chief of staff.
So that kind of argument
is going to to stand for other people.
The judge also mentioned the Hatch Act,
which limits
what an employee can do
that is political versus federal.
So I think that this is going to
be bad news for other people
who want to go in this direction.
One thing I think we should remember.
Donald Trump wants to delay these cases.
His goal is to push all these
trials past the election.
So even though this ruling has come down,
I don't think it means he won't try to
to do the same thing.
Let me get Gloria's reaction.
A lengthy, 49 page decision
that was just released. Right.
And we're just going through it.
But I think my colleagues here
have gotten to the crux of the matter,
which is that what the court is saying
is that Mark Meadows kind of overstepped
and that he wasn't acting
as a chief of staff should act
he was actually acting as an adjunct
to the Trump campaign.
And when you mention the Hatch Act,
Wolf, you're not supposed to do that.
You're at
when you're working in the White House,
you work for the government.
You don't work for a campaign.
And there's a line here
that says the Constitution
does not provide any basis
for executive branch involved.
With state
election and post-election
procedures, period.
It is not your job
that was not part of your job.
So you can't claim
that this should be moved
because you were just doing your job
because that's not your job
and you are acting
unofficially.
Yeah.
Just to add one quick sentence here,
it says When questioned
about the scope of his authority,
Meadows
was unable to explain
the limits of his authority
other than his inability
to stump for the president
or work on behalf of the campaign.
So so once again,
it shows there there is a clear line.
But he didn't want to define it.
And I think to Gloria's point to about,
you know,
the difference between, again, state
and federal responsibilities
and running their elections
the judge gets to that in this order.
We saw,
you know,
some of this play out in the Meadows
hearing where Georgia
Secretary of State Brad
Raffensperger was a witness
and essentially said
the federal government
doesn't play a role
in certifying our elections
in this order.
The judge says the court concludes
if it were to agree
with Meadows arguments regarding removal
and removal,
removal of federal court,
the court would have to turn a blind eye
to the express constitutional power
granted to the states
to determine their election procedures.
So he's again saying
this was a state job
to decide how they were going to certify
their elections,
to decide to certify their elections.
This wasn't
something that fell under the role
of the White House chief of staff.
I want to bring in Michael Moore,
a former U.S.
attorney who's
also carefully taking a look
at this decision.
The ruling says,
as you know, Michael,
that Meadows himself testified
that working for the Trump campaign
would be outside the scope
of a White House chief of staff.
So what do you make of this decision?
Well, I'm glad to be with all of you.
It's not necessarily
an unexpected decision.
We thought it could go either way.
I mean, and just getting the order.
So it strikes me
that there will be an appeal directly
from this.
It's interesting to hear
some of
the recitations
as it relates to the federal government's
role in state elections.
There are about 12 federal agencies
that participate
in monitoring state elections.
And you can kind of
go down the list, DOJ,
make sure that voting rights
are protected.
That's something that is in the purview
of the federal government.
DHS, Homeland Security
monitor cyber crime
as it relates to elections,
even those that are held in the state
when they have all federal office.
So there will be arguments to be made
and there might be some
room at the 11th Circuit
and certainly at the Supreme Court.
But we talk about what role it is.
I think the question is,
was there a federal involvement
in certifying it?
Certainly there there is not
but an inquiry into
the election, I think, may
be an issue that comes
up on the politics, but we'll hear that.
I don't think this hurts
Trump necessarily.
I think there'll be some other people
who will not find
necessarily a favorable ear in the court.
But certainly this
as it relates to Trump,
ends up delaying things.
And I think Jamie is correct
This case now goes to the 11th Circuit.
This appeal will it will
then wander its way to the Supreme Court.
Have you heard
even the trial judge
earlier this week
as he was suggesting
that those appeals are causing him
concern as he thinks about scheduled
the case of postponing those trials?
Emily Copeland is with us as well,
a former federal prosecutor.
Amy Lee,
what do you think this means for Trump?
His lawyers, as you well know,
have signaled
that he will try to move his case
from a state court to a federal court
Hey, Wolf.
Well, his lawyers
actually said we're thinking about it.
They didn't make a commitment.
And they have 30 days
from the date of his arraignment.
And I would say here
from when he filed the waiver
of formal arraignment
to make that decision.
I think all of us
think that Mark Meadows,
if anyone had the best chance
of getting the case removed
because he did have
some duties
that he said were inarguably
for the president.
You know,
it was interesting,
the breakdown in this order.
The court said,
look at the heart of the matter
when you consider
what the act is,
you can't just say that
any old act is enough.
You can't say that
scheduling calls
or setting meetings were over
overt act here.
It had to go to the heart of the matter
I think Mr.
Trump's problem is going to be
is that all of these calls
went to the heart of the matter.
He was acting as candidate Trump
rather than President Trump.
And I'm sure his lawyers
are going to give this order
a close read.
Let me go back to Sara understanding
you're getting some
more information
on how this order was unfolding
and what happens next.
Yeah, I mean,
I want to talk a little bit about again,
we talked about the Hatch Act
and whether or not
that was going to be
a persuasive argument for prosecutors
who said this sort of defines
that if you're a federal official,
you can't be engaged
in getting paid
by the federal government.
You can't get involved in power.
Right. Exactly.
And the judge writes to this in his order
and says The Hatch Act is helpful
in defining the outer
limit of the scope of the White House.
Chief of staff's authority.
The state argues and Meadows agrees
that he is bound by the Hatch Act,
a law that prohibits federal employees
from engaging in political activity.
These prohibitions on executive
branch employees,
including the White House
chief of staff,
reinforce the court's conclusion
that Meadows has not shown
how his actions relate
to the scope of his federal
executive branch office.
Federal officer removal
is thereby in opposite.
Again, this is an appealable decision.
And I think
just because this is something
that Mark Meadows loss
does not mean that this is the route
that Donald Trump's attorneys
are not going to go down.
I think that the reason that they said
they may remove to federal court
is that they wanted to see how
this was going
to play out for Mark Meadows.
They wanted to see what arguments
maybe seemed persuasive to the judge
and what arguments fell flat,
because this will be the same judge
who is ultimately going
to hear the arguments from Donald Trump
if he tries to move this case
to federal court.
And to Michael Moore's point.
This was something that came up
in this sort
of scheduling back and forth about
are we going to go forward
with all of these 19 defendants
going to trial
in October of this year,
or is it just going to be Ken
Hasbro and Sidney Powell?
And so
it'll be more for that state court
judge to chew over as he tries
to set out a schedule for these folks.